[Music]  we took out a dreadlock what cost there  are something you cannot solve by  jumping in X log something up that first  battle sequence shows his Achilles heel  which is he wants to be the hero but his  old heroics aren't necessarily what is  needed at this moment it's like when  someone drops a hard truth on your just  you rejected immediately just because  you're not ready to learn that yeah you  know okay yeah  the theme of mentors runs through this  whole series and to me it made a lot of  sense that Leia would be that to po-po  is her protege and in a way I think she  thinks of him as Han he's very  dominating and he doesn't listen to her  so we have some moments together you're  demoted oh wait that was one of the  first things that we shot and I think we  did 24 takes that was very surreal to be  slapped by Princess Leia repeatedly  there is more feistiness this time that  I really like now there is Leia again  [Music]